today we are celebrating Day of the Dead
and next week boracha Mexican Cantina in
Green Valley Ranch will be celebrating
with specialty cocktails and more here
tell us more all about it we have Omar's
the general manager and Haley is the
bartender welcome you guys thank you
thanks for having us get the memo about
doing your makeup no I did not I didn't
know okay tell everyone about the
restaurant because there's like a Day of
the Dead theme inside the restaurant
yeah so on the on the second we're going
to paint half our staff's face and we're
gonna do three specialty cocktails for a
Day of the Dead to celebrate uh we have
the marigold Margarita we have La bruja
Paloma and we have the what is the
Katrina yeah
you're gonna make one of these cocktails
for us today which one are you gonna
make and what ingredients do you have
because people at home watching they
want to make it they can do that this
weekend what ingredients are you putting
in the cocktail absolutely so this is
our Marigold Margarita So today we're
going to be using esplan Reposado
tequila all right and then Triple Sec
blood orange and we have a little bit of
lime juice I got a point in the ounce I
don't know if you can see this I'm gonna
hold something up I don't know where to
hold it up at but look at that is that a
skull inside this glass and what is that
made out of a blood orange blood orange
skull it's right there on camera that is
really cool okay pour some tequila on
top of that thing at Walmart when it
comes to food what kind of food do you
guys offer uh we have salt Mexican food
we're also going to have a special
dessert A Day of the Dead dessert as
well okay it's gonna be a tres leches
cake uh sounds good it's gonna be really
good and I love the fact that you guys
are gonna be doing half the face on
Wednesday and you guys are celebrating
on Wednesday the 2nd is when everything
takes place correct then why is that Tom
that's the official day of the dead
November 2nd so we're going to do that
to keep a tradition I love it shake it
up we get it going I think it'll be good
and then what are some of the spices we
have here with the drink uh so this is a
tahin ram okay yeah so we would um Rim
this all right a glass with the lime
juice and the tahini okay yeah or you
can get it with salt uh we can also do
it with sugar that's perfect pour it in
there this is good then you guys are
open seven days a week correct and
someone wants to come in for dinner
reservations you think required how's
that one they're definitely required but
we also take walk-ins okay that's
perfect we open up at four um on the
weekends we open up at 10 for football
and everything and then two I over here
I love how the table is decorated this
kind of gives you an idea of how the
restaurant has the theme going
throughout the restaurant the flowers
down here do they go into the drink yeah
yes we always
Yep they're edible flowers so we put a
lime wheel why don't you why don't you
eat when there's Elmer incredible
it looks so good it is so festive here
on the table it is so festive inside the
restaurant definitely all of this is
happening next Wednesday with especially
cocktails and stuff anything else coming
up in the future for you guys we also
have New Years coming up we'll have a DJ
uh we'll also you know close off and
just have a little dance floor off to
the side as well too so it'll be really
cool I love it awesome Omar Haley thank
you so much for joining us and we got to
do full makeup next year right